회사에 복지 체계가 혹시 있습니까?
자기가 못하는데
회사여야 해줄 수 있는 걸 해주면
그 사람들이 좋아하겠다
그래서 제가 했던 게 세 가지인데
첫 번째는 커피 같은 것들을
저희 카페를 만들어서 공짜로 줬어요
우리도 탕비실에 제가 커피 나드렸죠?
그 커피 사람이 이렇게 내려서 주나요?
어 맞습니다
두 번째는 이제 아난티나 시그니엘 레지던스를
저희 직원들이 이렇게 신청해서 써요
컷!
커피까지만 듣도록 하겠습니다
저는 다음 질문!
자 오늘 해피 떨스의 신나게 시작을 해보도록 하겠습니다
예
후우
자 오늘 저와 함께 또 슈카님이 함께 해주셨습니다
아 모자 거의 제 모자인데
사실 지금 슈카님이 쓰고 계세요
원샷 좀 잡아주세요
하나 둘
흉하다 흉해
아까 나이도 비슷하시네요
비슷해요 비슷해요
원빈씨가 저보다 한 살형이에요
한 살형이에요?
한 살형이에요
제가 형이 아니고
원빈씨가
자 오늘 저희 해피 떨스데이
아 너무나도 모시기 힘든 분을 또 모셔서
많은 다양한 이야기를 할 텐데요
저는 오늘 아정당의 김민기 대표님을 모시고
이야기 이어나가도록 하겠습니다
어서 오십시오
아 네 안녕히 계십시오
반갑습니다
안녕하세요
야 원빈을 광고 모델로 쓴 남자
일단 간단하게 아정당이 뭔지 모르시는 분들도 좀 계실 것 같아요
맞습니다
예 그래서 간단하게 기업 이야기 또는 어떤 기업인지 좀 간단하게 부탁드리겠습니다
저희 회사는 인터넷, 하입, 정수기, 렌탈, 휴대폰부터 시작해서
이제 업력이 7년차 되면서
같은 맥락에 있는 이사, 부동산, 인테리어까지 확장함으로써
홈서비스 전반을 다루고 있습니다
7년 되셨다며요
네 맞습니다
근데 얼마 전에 뭐라 그러죠? 엑시트?
엑시트라기보다는 지분 이전
아 지분 이전
왜냐면 엑시트는 뭔가 이제 제가 나가야 될 것 같은데
계약서 조항을 다 말씀드릴 수도 없지만
계약 유지가 10년
이렇게 되어 있었기 때문에
아 일부 지분을 이전했다
이제 51%를 이전했습니다
아 51%
네 맞습니다
아
기업가치 얼마에 이전하셨죠?
저희가 3천억 조금 넘게 했습니다
51%면
네 네
1,500억
1,500억을
네 네
이 매각하신 거잖아요
어 맞습니다
실례지만 그 연세가
아 저는 89년생입니다
89년생
네
89년생인데
저는 85년생
뭐라고 85세시라고요?
85?
58 개띠셔?
85년생
아 85년생
아
89년생인데
스타트업 6년 반 만에
그 기업가치 3천억으로
1,500억원을 지분이전
지분이전을 했다는 거잖아요
제가 정말 정말 몰라서 하는 얘기인데요
네 네
그렇게 지분이전하면
계좌에 바로 돈이 들어옵니까?
사람이 지분이전에 돈을 줬어
저렴한 얘기를 해 지금
아 궁금하잖아
대표님 모셔서
띠딩 하고 이렇게 들어옵니까 이렇게?
맞습니다 10억씩 10억씩 계속
이제 1분에 한 60억씩 나눠서
이제 계속 들어옵니다
아 진짜로
150번이?
맞습니다
그거 어떤 기분일까?
1분에 계속 10억씩 들어와
계속
기분이 어때요 그럴 때?
사실 지금도 조금 많이 얼떨떨하고
그 돈을 받은 지 이제 뭐
한 달 정도 지났는데
그냥 아무것도 안 하고 있습니다
한 달밖에 안 되셨어요?
네 맞습니다
확정된 게 이제 한 달 정도 밖에 안 됐습니다
진짜
형
표현이 좋다고
아니 그러지 말고
형이라 부르지마
투자자님
조슈카친구들 기업 소개 좀 해주세요
아 굉장히 훌륭한 사업구조를 갖고 있으니까
음 일단 단명합니다
여기 들어오면
저 보시면 아시죠
얼굴이 안 좋아져
6개월 만에 늙었어 늙었어
대신 이런 거 할 수 있잖아요
아 그렇지 그렇지
요만 센 삽니다 요만 센
하여튼 오늘 비교를 한번 여쭤볼까요
비교를
예 알겠습니다
저희 대표님 오셨는데
슈카월드 좀 보신 적 있으세요 혹시?
슈카월드는 제가 거의 3년 동안 영상 하나도 빠짐없이 다 봤습니다
아 진짜요?
네
기업을 운영하시면서 슈카월드가 도움을 준 적 있습니까?
혹시 슈카월드 컨텐츠가?
어 막 직접적인 건 아니지만
없어 없어
없는 거야?
이제 간접적으로는 뭐 예를 들면은 면접 볼 때
그쪽에서 자꾸 자기의 상식을 슈카월드로 얘기해 주시는 거예요
근데 너무 저랑 이게 생각하는 게 겹치니까
아 이분은 약간 슈카월드만 보고 세상을 바라보시는 거나
약간 그런 정도의
훌륭한 분이시네요
맞습니다
뽑으셨습니까?
어?
아 안 뽑아
근데 오늘 좀 그걸 여쭤보고 싶어요
어떻게 하면은 거의 30살쯤에 스타트업을 만드신 거잖아요
창업을 해서 불과 6년 7년 만에 대단히 큰 기업으로 일구실 수 있는지
그거 오늘 알려주고 가셔야 돼요
맞아요
왜냐면 저희가 그래야 되거든요
아 제가 긴장하지 않는다면은 모든 것을
질문해 주시는 거 모든 걸 다 알려드리고
중요한 건 긴장하지 않는다면 우리가 긴장을 풀어드려야 돼
뭘 해야 되지?
그럼 아지라도 벗을까?
하하하하하하하하하하하하하하하하하하하하하하하하하
자 오늘 이제 우리 아정당에 대해서 좀 알아가고 싶거든요
초창기부터 그 스토리 좀 말씀좀 해주세요
아까 이제 스타트업 창업 말씀해주셨는데
사실 저는 시작할 때 스타트업이라고 생각은 안 했었어요
원래는 이제 현대종합설계라는 데서 건축공학을 전공해서
이제 건축설계를 했습니다
근데 이제 원래는 서울에서 근무해야 되는 건데
제가 대구 사람이라서 울산으로 파견을 보냈고
근데 이제 파견하면 사실 마치고 할 게 없잖아요.
그래서 공부, 부업 이런 거 하다가
저희 부모님이 시장에서 용달하시는데
그 용달 수수료 이런 것들이 너무 많은 거예요.
그래가지고 열심히 일하는 사람은 돈을 많이 못 벌고
그리고 고객도 돈을 내는데 제대로 된 품질을 못 보장받고 해서
이걸 다이렉트로 연결해주는 네이버 카페를 만들어야겠다 해서
회사 마치면 그 카페를 조금씩 조금씩 조성하기 시작했고
그게 한 14개월 정도 됐을 때까지는 무급이었는데
그 취지가 너무 좋잖아요.
그게 잘 돼서 회원 수가 한 4만 명 정도가 됐어요.
인원이 많으니까 인터넷 가입, 정수기 렌탈, 광고가 들어왔고
근데 그 업체들이 너무 못해서
너무 못해서
저한테 자꾸 불만을 표출하길래
차라리 이거면 내가 하는 게 낫겠다.
그래서 제가 막 여기저기
인터넷 가입할 수 없냐고 계속 물어보다가
제 체감상으로는 한 200번째 물어봤을 때 갑자기
뭐 한번 해봐라 라고
아 그러면은 회사 다니면서 해봐야지 해서
저희 작은 이모랑 저랑 이렇게 투잡으로 시작했는데
그게 이제 너무 잘 돼서 지금까지 왔습니다.
근데 오시는 분들 중에
아정당이 어떤 이름인지 모르시는 분들이 있을 것 같거든요.
간단하게 설명 좀
사실 아정당 이름은 저희 어머니 성함이 아정이거든요.
엄마 이름이세요?
네, 맞습니다.
함부로 그러면 기업 이름을 부르면 안 되겠네요.
아정은 어머님
아정이라고요? 지금 어머님 이름을 지금
어머님당
아정님당
네, 어머니 성함이셨어요?
네, 맞아요.
처음에 시작할 때는 커질 걸 생각하지 않고
내가 진짜 열심히 할 수밖에 없는 이름을 지었으면 좋겠다.
그리고 조금 더 나아가서는 좋은 기운을 받았으면 좋겠다라는
그 두 가지 의미를 담아서 좀 갖다 붙인 거긴 합니다.
그걸 선택했을 때 약간 부담은 되지 않았어요?
그렇죠.
왜냐하면 사업 명의인데, 회사 기업 명의인데
사실 저희 친형은 엄청 뜯어말렸습니다.
그래서 너 사업하는데 왜 어머니 이름 갖다 쓰냐고
그럼 욕먹으면 엄마가 욕먹는 거 아니냐고
그 생각한 게 있어요.
혹시 우리 슈카
우리 엄마 이름 아니야.
어떤 엄마가 이름이 슈카야?
무슨 생각을 하는 거예요.
우리 엄마 이름 아니에요.
그렇지 그렇지
불과 6년 반 전이잖아요.
네, 맞습니다.
지금 직원이 몇 분 정도예요?
총 합쳐서 한 850분 정도.
계열사 다 합쳐서
850명?
네, 맞습니다.
저희도 목표가 인력을 두 배씩 늘리는 거
나는 목표를 딱 세웠더니
우리 니니라는 친구가
그런 거 좀 하지 말아요.
여기서 사람 많이 뽑고
또 비용 많이 들게
항상 그러고 있거든요.
어떻게 생각하십니까?
근데 그분은 회사를 생각해 주시네요, 진짜.
아, 아닌가요?
우리 슈카 대표님은
회사는 생각 안 하죠.
아, 그래.
편을 들어 가야죠.
대표님 그 직원 중에
1번
네
왜요?
직원 물어봐가지고 뭘 물어봐
아저씨는 거기
PD님 왜 나와서
중요한 겁니다.
그 충신 모드로
열심히 하십시오 하면서
계속 이렇게 좋은 말 해주시는 분이 있고
달콤하게
파이팅, 대표님 파이팅
두 번째
충신인데 입에 써?
아하
뭐만 하면 뭐라 그래
막 들어와서
대표님 잠깐만 저를 좀 봐요
그러면 회의실에 들어와서 왜
브레이크를 잡아, 브레이크
엑셀이 그 브레이크가 있어요.
어느 직원을 조금 더
제 개인적으로는
후자가 훨씬 더 나은 것 같습니다.
브레이크 잡아주신
브레이크보다 자기가
올바른 것을 계속 얘기하는 것
하하하하하하하
이 기업이 있으면 이렇게 확
고성장하는 구간이 쫙 있잖아요.
이거 정말
야, 이게 이래도 되나?
이런 순간이 분명히 있을 것 같아요.
어느 정도가 지나고 나서
그 곡선을 쫙 텄어요?
그 곡선이 사실 제가 봤을 때
원빈님 섭외인 것 같아요.
하아
사실 저희 업종이 대중적이지는 않거든요.
이제 휴대폰 통신은
남자 분들이 좀 더 좋아하시고
인터넷이나 휴대폰 이런 거 바꾸시니까
이사는 좀 나이 있으신 분들이 좋아하는데
좀 관심 있어 하는데
이제 원빈님을 섭외하니까
모든 분들에게 관심이 좀 많이 쌓여가지고
잘 된 것 같습니다.
너무너무 궁금한데요?
물어보지 마세요.
하하하하하하
자네가 뭘 물어볼 지 알 거 같아.
원빈님
물어보지 마세요.
물어보면 안 되나?
원빈님이 광고 잘 안 찍으시잖아요.
어떻게 이게
메이드가 됐습니까 이게 섭외가?
아, 나 그 과정이 되게 궁금한 것 같아요.
사실 저희가 열심히 쫓아다녀서 된 게 아닌가 싶어요.
운도 있었고 유명하신 분들은 저희가 광고를 맡기는 게 아니고 그쪽에서 선택을 하는 거거든요.
그래서 처음에는 그냥 아정당 있네 라고만 하시다가
원빈님 주변에서 저희 아정당을 좀 좋게 이용하신 분이 있었나 봐요.
그래서 그걸로 조금 더 플러스 점수 얻고 그리고 저희가 직원들이 다 젊거든요.
그래서 젊은 사람들이 왜 이렇게 열심히 해? 해가지고 이 두 개가
그러면 이런 시장에서 좋은 회사가 되는 거에서 내가 조금이라도 기여하고 싶다라는 생각이 있으셔서
저희랑 좀 같이 해주신 것 같습니다.
그러니까 되게 원빈님께서는 젊은 기업의 젊은 친구들을 위해서 내가 뭔가 힘을 실어주고 싶다라는
그게 좀 맞아떨어졌다.
아정당, 삼성전자, SK아이템
고르고 있는데 고르고 있는데
아정당 중간중간에 핸드폰 정수기 뭐 이렇게 쭉 말씀해 주시는데
모르시는 분들이 계시니까 사업 구조나 사업 모델이 뭔지도 좀 설명을 해주셔야 될 것 같아요.
맞습니다. PPT로 띄워놓고
저희는 정보 비대칭이 심한 영역에 들어가 있는 업종의 회사라고 보시면 돼요.
그러니까 생수처럼 매일매일 사 먹는 것 같은 경우는
내가 정보를 많이 알고 올바른 판단을 할 수 있지만
이사나 인터넷이나 휴대폰은 3년, 5년 만에 한 번씩 하다 보니까
할 때마다 새롭게 공부해야 되는 경우가 많잖아요.
아, 맞아요.
근데 이게 너무 힘드니까 한 업종에서 한 업종에서 다 고객들을 만족시켜 드리면
어, 아정당이니까 다른 업종에서도 잘할 거야 라는 생각이 들게끔
이제 구매 주기가 긴 것들에 있어서 사업을 확장하고 있는 회사라고 봐주시면 됩니다.
그럼 예를 들면 이런 건가요?
요즘 제가 이사해 보니까 이사도 잘하는 팀이 있더라고요.
네, 맞습니다.
그 같은 포장 이사인데 유명한 팀들은 이미 뭐 몇 달 뒤, 몇 개월 뒤까지 예약이 끝났고
그 엄마들은 아니라고 깔끔하게 하는 팀이 있고
어, 그 팀이 있어요?
있어, 있어.
아, 진짜요?
네, 유명한 팀들이 있어요.
그런 분들 예약하려고 하면 이게 얼마인지도 좀 모르고
맞습니다.
그런 정보 비대칭을 해결해 주는 그런 거는 이해하면 될까요?
이사를 예시로 들어주셨는데 방금 그 팀도 사실 컨디션에 따라서 다를 수가 있잖아요.
왜냐하면 내가 해주는 이 고객이 5년 뒤에 만날지도,
10년 뒤에 만날지도 몰라요.
그러니까 당연히 안 만난다 생각하고 수행을 하거든요.
그러니까 진짜 잘하시는 분은 드물어요.
어차피 안 만날 건데.
한철 장사하는 사람들의 마인드랑 비슷하거든요.
근데 저희가 아정당이라는 레이어를 씌워주고
그 업체가 만약에 못한다 하면 저희가 대신 고객님한테 입금을 해드리거든요.
보상 같은 것들을.
그리고 저희는 250개의 파손이나 이런 민원률을 다 계속 데이터로 보고
매일매일 아침 저희 1시간씩 회의를 하고 있는데
맨 밑에 있는 그 분들은 계속 쳐내요.
그리고 그분한테 전화 직접 드려가지고 우리가 실제로 보고 있다라고 얘기해드리면
내가 만약에 이번에 이 고객한테 잘 못하면 다음 건수가 없을 수도 있겠구나 이렇게 생각하시고
계속 열심히 하시게 되는 거죠.
업무에 대한 어떤 결과물 가지고 그걸 업데이트를 계속 한다는 얘기네요.
네, 맞습니다.
그럼 앞에 그 핸드폰은 뭔가요?
핸드폰은 이제 두 가지 종류가 있는데 통신사로 개통해가지고
그 지원금을 받으시는 유형이 하나 있고요.
하는 유형은 이제 알뜰폰 많이 쓰시는데 저희가 알뜰폰 사업자예요.
그래서 알뜰폰을 개통하시는 유형이 하나 있습니다.
아정당이 와서 개통을 하면 뭐가 좋나요?
두 가지가 있는데 첫 번째는 본사로부터 받는 수당을 고객님께 많이 드릴 수 있습니다.
뭐 여러 가지 매장이 있지만 저희가 가장 공격적인 매장은 아정당 신돌임점인데
거기에서 현금 지원금을 굉장히 많이 드리고 있습니다.
사실 마진도 얘기하고 싶었는데.
저희 직원분들이 얘기하지 말래?
마진을 얘기해도 될 만큼 근데 왜 하면 안되나요?
얘기하지 마요.
저 오래 살고 싶어요.
예전에 마진에 관련해서 한 번 또 크게 한 번 다른 사업이긴 합니다만
뭐 이런 여러 가지 그게 있어가지고
그래서 말씀드리고 싶은 거는 여기 댓글에도 있으시길래
그 신돌임이 사실 더 다른 곳보다 많이 줄 수 있는 경쟁적인 정책을 받는 게
신돌임이 사실 더 다른 곳보다 많이 줄 수 있는 경쟁적인 정책을 받는 게
있는 것도 있어요.
그래서 저희가 신돌임으로 아정당에 오시면은 진짜
이래도 되나 싶을 정도의
맞습니다.
그냥 후회가 없습니다.
아 후회가 없다.
그리고 개수가 있으면은 또 본사로부터 더 많은 수당을 받을 수 있거든요.
그래서 고객님한테 제일 많이 줄 수밖에 없는 구조가 짜여지니까
저희가 지금 KT나 LG 이런 본사랑 다이렉트로 계약한 곳이 한 세개 밖에 없는데
그 중에 저희가 하나거든요.
그래서 많이 드릴 수 밖에 없다.
대형사니까 바게닝 파워가 있으니까
그렇죠 소매점에서 하는 것보다
도매점 이런 이마트 같은 데서 하는 게 더 싸듯이
저희도 그렇게 되어 있고
좀 진정성 있고자 말씀드리면
혹시라도 저희 상담원한테 이야기했는데 적다
아니면 아까 이사로 넘어가서
이사 분쟁 때문에 뭔가 힘들었는데
본사가 시원찮다 하면 제 연락처로
여기에다가 이야기해드릴 수도 있습니다
연락처 띄우는 거 아니죠?
하면 안 돼 하면 안 돼
근데 전화로 주시면 전화를 잘 못
제가 폰 한 개밖에 안 써가지고
전화로 주시면 전화를 많이 못 받고
진짜 이걸로 연락을
왜냐하면 저희도 개선을 해야 되니까
저희 회사에 대한 민원이나 상품이 적다
고객센터에서 안 맞춰준다
불가능하거든요
저희는 다 맞춰드릴 수 있으니까
근데 정말 농담이 아니라
너무 많은 민원 때문에
정말 개인적인 지인이나 부모님하고 통화해야 될
방해가 될 수 있잖아요
전화가 많이 오면 그렇게 되죠
근데 그렇게 드리자면
듣는 것들이 진짜 저희 고객의 소리가 너무 많아서
사실 그거를 개선하면 또 전화가 안 오니까
그게 등락이 좀 있는 거 같습니다
알겠습니다
저도 번호 하나만 좀 알려주세요
자 그리고 저희 회사를 운영하다 보면
형 일단 회사를 운영하다 보면
와 이거 이러다가 망하는 거 아니야?
위기가 분명 있을 것 같아요
지금은 막 휴대폰이나 다 지금 잘 되는 이야기도 있지만
우리 청년들이 나도 저렇게 뭔가 부푼 꿈이 있을 텐데요?
네 우리 청년들이 나도 저렇게 뭔가 부푼 꿈이 있을 텐데요?
중간에 정말 역경 가장 힘들었던 거 뭐가 있었습니까?
어...
없으셨다
그냥 역경이 없는 거야
지금을 잘 뽑으셨네
우리는 모든 게 역경인데
우리는 하나에서 열 가지 역경이 역경이 역경이 역경이잖아요
아 역경은 사실 미화돼가지고
어 그때는 성장의 기회였지
지금 막 이렇게 떠올라가지고 말씀을 못 드렸던 것 같고
사실 힘든 거는 초창기 때 그때가 제일 힘들죠
초창기 때
계속 따박따박 월급 받다가
직원들 내일 출근하는데 이거 전화 안 오네 어떡하지
이런 것들이 이제 익숙하지 않았을 때 굉장히 힘들었습니다
매출이 안 생기는데
월급을 대표님 입장에서 직원분들이 이 회사에 대해서 만족을 해야 될 거 아니야
아 복지가 정말 미쳤다 너무너무 좋다
이런 것들 좀 자신 있게 말씀하실 수 있는 회사의 복지 체계가 혹시 있습니까?
사실 저희가 급여나 환경이나 이런 거는 모르겠지만
복지는 정말 좋은 거 같아요
그 이유가 인재가 제일 중요하니까
어떻게 사람을 많이 뽑지 하다가
자기가 못하는데 회사여야 해줄 수 있는 걸 해주면 그 사람들이 좋아하겠다
그래서 제가 했던 게 세 가지인데
첫 번째는 커피 같은 것들을 저희 카페를 만들어서 공짜로 줬어요
왜냐면 하루에 두 잔 사 먹으면 11,000원인데
제가 드리면 부가세라든가
그리고 이제 줄 때 소득세 안 떼고 주니까
한 30-40%가 절감되고
그걸 누군가가 만들어서 주면
카페 마진도 절감돼서 커피를 계속 공짜로 드리는 게 제일 좋았고
두 번째는 이제 아람티나 시그니엘 레지던스를 저희 직원들이 이렇게 신청해서 써요
컷!
커피까지만 듣도록 하겠습니다
저는 다음 질문
피디님 이력서 하나만 좀 뽑아주세요 이력서
이거 라이브니?
녹화본으로 내주세요 녹화본으로
아람티 시그니엘 레지던스를 어떻게 하신다고요?
그걸 이제 저희가 임대로 해가지고 직원들한테 계속 이렇게 드리는 거죠
계속 말씀해 주세요
네 왜냐면 아람티나는 1년에 60박이고 시그니엘을 361 살 필요는 없잖아요
그래서 직원이 많으니까 그걸 그냥 하루씩 이렇게 우리 나눠서 그쪽을 이용하자라는 의미로
이제 회사에서만 할 수 있는 걸 하고 있는 거예요
혹시 대표님 대표님 실인데 가끔 대우해 주시는 거 아닐까요?
아닙니다
그럴 수 있잖아 대표님 실인데 날카롭잖아
퀴즈 중에 6개월?
축하해!
다 쓰고?
다행히 세무조사가 나왔을 때 똑같은 얘기를 했었거든요
오우 야 역시 진짜 야
365일 동안 이런 게 말이 되냐 해서 저희가 이제 신청했고
직원이 실제로 간 것들 막 사진 찍거나 아니면 카톡한 것들 있잖아요
그런 걸로 다 하니까 아 뭐
아니구나
네 잘 설명됐습니다
근데 생각해 우리도 그 탕비실에 제가 그 커피 나 드렸죠?
맞아요 맞아요
커피 그 커피 사람이 이렇게 내려서 주나요?
어 맞습니다
아 기계 이런 거 편집해야지
기계가 내려주잖아
해줬어 나만 먹더라 근데
나도 먹고 있어요
원빈 씨가 또 광고 모델로서 다 나오면서
야 이게 진짜 이게 너무나도 중요하다라는 걸 느끼시면서
앞으로도 이 마케팅 쪽에 조금 힘을 많이 실을 어떤 전략이 좀 있으세요? 어떻게?
사실 저희 전략은 당연히 마케팅 잘 되는 게 전략인데
처음부터 생각을 했던 게 사업의 본질이 안 좋으면 마케팅이 안 되더라고요
아 본질?
네
그러니까 뭐 예를 들면은 저희가 상조를 마케팅하는데
지금 상조회사에서 기존에 있는 거 방식대로 그대로 하면은
저희 걸 들 이유가 없거든요
아
이미 상조는 지금 천만 명인가 엄청 인원이 많은 사람들이 가입돼있기 때문에
그 사람들보다 혁신적으로 좋아야만 저희 쪽으로 넘어오고 있어서
전략을 사람들이 우리 아정당을 이용하지 않으면 바보가 되게끔 먼저 만들고
그 뒤에 마케팅을 하자 이런 주의로 계속 해왔습니다.
해왔었어요 그래서 저희는 마케팅 을 최대한 내재화해서 하고 있고
같은 경쟁사 대비해서 마케팅 비용 을 고객 건당 한 7분의 1 8분의 1
밖에 쓰진 않거든요 그만큼 저희를 이용할 수밖에 없게 하는 마케팅
을 하고 있고 그 사업 전략에 대해서 조금 더 고민하고 있는 것 같습니다
대표님 그리고 또 질문이 여기 또 써 있는 게 저도 궁금해요 재테크
는 어떻게 아 제일 중요하다 재테크 같은 경우는 다 말씀드리면 저는
주식을 못하고 있습니다 왜냐하면 은 제가 직장인 일 때 1년치 월급을
코인의 한 이틀만에 날렸던 적이 있어 가지고 그 이틀만에 1년치
연봉을요? 네 1,100억 넣으면 안돼요
그거 복구할까? 1,100억 넣으면 안돼 김민기 대표님이죠 민기야 넣으면 안돼
넣을 것 같은데요?
그때도 당시에 이제 주변에 있는 분들이 다 번다 하니까 저도 넣고
일주일만에 2배를 2배까지 이제 찍고 번 건 아니죠 안 받았으니까 2배 찍고
와 돈이 복사 빨리 나올까 했는데 그 다음날 이제 이렇게 됐는데 다행히도
한 3년을 존버 해가지고 그래도 본전은 찾았는데 그때 경험이 나는 돈도 돈
이지만 계속 보는거 시간과 에너지가 너무 힘들더라고요 성격이
절대 하면 안되겠다 해서 근데 이제 이번에 돈이 생기니까
엄청 많은 연락을 받으... 직접 찾아와 주시더라고요
그래서 제일 안전한 국채에다가 넣었습니다
국채에다가?
국채 하나에 100억인데 한 15개 정도는 플렉스할 수 있는
근데 그거 국채 빼가지고
혹시 슈카 지분을 살 생각은 없으세요? 혹시?
훌륭한 질문이야
드디어 자네가 지분 사고 지분을 한 건가?
오늘 마지막에
좋은 질문이에요
명확하게 대답해주세요
이거 약간 TMI일 수도 있지만
그 생각하시는 가치가 얼마이신가요?
잠깐만
아 이거 잠깐만요
또 보시는 분들 중에서도
돈을 넣고 싶어 하시는 분들이 있을 것 같아서
한번 여쭤봤습니다
아 한번만 보고 계세요?
너만 봐라 봐
자 아무튼 국채에 재테크를 하고 계신다
자 이렇게 또 말씀을 해주셨습니다
자 그러면 저희 회사에 대해서
많은 분들께서 도대체 그 아정당
아까 뭐 1,500억 이야기도 나오고
뉴스에 이미 많이 나왔잖아요
도대체 뭐 어떤
세계를
성장률을 좀 보이고 있길래
시장에서는 이렇게 좀 바라보고 있는가
아마 오늘 준비하셨던 자료들도 좀 있을 텐데
이거 한번 보면 좋을 것 같습니다
아 예 알겠습니다
감사하게도
아니 2021년
아 이게 이제 법인 설립 기준으로
만들어진 거 같아요
저희 개인 사업자 같은 경우는
19년도부터 시작이 되었고요
근데 이제 감사하게도 잘 커가지고
지금은 좀 성장이 빨랐습니다
근데 이제 매출은 당연히
고객의 사은품까지 들어갔고
이제 공급이 들어가 있는 거기 때문에
실제 영업이익률은 많이 낮습니다
그래서 조금 뻥튀기가 돼있다 라고
보이시는 것 같고요
넘겨주세요
안 한 티 들어가있네요
빨리 넘겨주세요
안 한 티 안 한 티
이제 보시는 시청자분들도
그냥 정보라서 좋을 것 같은데
알뜰폰 싸다 알뜰폰 싸다 하는데
뭐 어떻게 싼 거예요
이게 프로모션이 좀 있어요
그러니까 알뜰폰이 싼 게
7개월 형은 24개월 형은 평생 형은
이렇게 세 가지 종류에서 싼 거를 잘 구분하셔야 돼요
그러니까 엄청 싸다 이런 걸 구분하셔야 돼요
이렇게 싸다 있는데
그게 7개월 뒤에 요금이 올라갈 수도 있고요
24개월 뒤에 요금이 올라갈 수도 있어요
다행히도 알뜰폰 같은 경우는
약정이 없어가지고
계속 메뚜기처럼 옮기셔도 되지만
그걸 잘 모르시고
계속 평생 쓸 건데
평생 형이 아닌 7개월 하면
엄청 크게 소개되면 보시는 거거든요
그래서 이거는 통신의 꿀팁이어서 정리를 했고요
뭐 저희 거에 대해서 이야기 드리면
저희 것도 뭐 24개월 이후 7개월 이런 것들이 있는데
뭐 1메가 bps는 뭐 만 원 이하고
그리고 이제
아 정당히 저 알뜰폰 사업을 하시는 거죠 지금
네 맞습니다
아 이거 본인 사업이잖아요
네 맞습니다 저희 사업자입니다
대신에 알뜰폰 가입하실 때
저희 상담해 가지고 하는 금액이랑
그냥 셀프 가입으로 하는 거랑 금액이 다르거든요
그래서 뭐가 유리해요
당연히 이제 상담 없이 알뜰폰 신청하는 게 훨씬 저렴하시죠
아 상담을 하면 인건비 들어가니까
예 맞습니다
그래서 또 젊으신 분들은 신청하는 거 전혀 어렵지 않으니까
신청하시기 편할 것 같아요
거라고 생각합니다 으 저는 또 궁금한게 4 다양한 사업을 좀 하시잖아요
아까 상조도 있었고 4 하십니다 근데 앞으로 후보 군들 더 있습니까 이
확장성 에 있어서 어떤 사업을 더 4 지금 구상을 하고 계시는지 자동차
무료 개그 중고차 맞습니다 사실 중고차 를 하고자 하는 마음이 제일
큽니다 지금 아 제일 커요 왜 진짜 뭐 아지 날카롭다 진짜 왜냐면 얼마전에
저희가 그 애니 차골라주 기록하고 있어 너무 아들 아요 봐도 모르겠더라
왜 차가 정확히 얼만지 그쵸 아까 불투명한 시장 그레이안 시장 가는게
저희의 pc 맞아서 예 중고차로 가고자 하는 마음이 큰데 지금은 이사가 민원이
없을 수 없잖아요 이사 그래서 이 이사를 완전 정점 찍고 중고차 가자고
생각을 하고 있습니다 그리고 이제 웨딩도 가고 싶고 뭐 예 예 예 웨딩은
하는 5년 뒤 뭐 10년 뒤가 되지 않을까 싶긴 한데 그냥 바램이 줘 아 요란 부터
문어 무덤 까지 하는게 생활 서비스의 제 발음이 가격이 좀 서서 투명한 게
많은 것 같아요 아저씨 등에 할 때 마저 와 줘 이게 얼만지는 모르는데
또 일단 뭐 달라는 대로 모아서 주는것 밖에 방법이 없으니까 그러면
이제는 자금 좀 되시니까 4 한 3대 업체 정도로 이렇게 탕 인수해서 삭
들어가면 4 조금 쉽게 들어갈 수 있지 않을까 아 저희가 인수 제한들 도 진짜
많이 봤는데요 그 분들이랑 조금 저희가 많이 보류하고 있는 것은 두
가지인데 저한테 정보를 아예 차단하고
안 알려 주시는 경우 그러니까 저한테 제대로 알려 줬을 때는 제가 계속
개선하려고 하니까 그걸 아예 안 알려 주시는 경우가 제일 커서 좀 보류하고
있는 거고 두번째는 계속 안 된다고 하시는 거죠 아 그거 이 시장 몰라서
그런 겁니다 아 그거 아 대표님 저도 지금 17년 한겁니다 이런식으로 하시는
경우가 많아서 아 그냥 우리가 처음부터 시작하는게 더 낫겠다 이렇게 생각하고
있어요 제가 사부 할 때 저거 정말 많이 경험을 했었거든요 최대한 생산자
쪽에 붙어서 이제 아 물건을 이렇게 하고 싶잖아요
우리도 물건이 사이버 문장으로 줄여서 말그대로 생산자 꺼 갖고와서 하려
보니까 어렵더라고요 차라리 젊은 사람들끼리 무조건 해보자 하는게 조금 더 성과가
좋았던 것 같습니다 그러지 말고 무조건 해보자 니들이 밥부터 해서 돼지 키우고
배추 키우고 당근 키우고 거기서부터해서 우리가 팔면 되잖아 그래서 그 사업이
없어졌어요 이런 경우 사업 부서를 하나 해서 뭔가 신사업을 가려고 했는데 막 막혔어요 네
막 여러 가지 이유가 있어요. 그 안에.
그런 것들도 많이 경험하시고 있잖아요, 지금.
맞습니다.
그런 경우에는 사실 해결은 제가 생각했을 때는
대표 많이 할 수 있다고 생각은 해요.
그게...
여기 앉으시지 뭐.
여기 어떻게 앉으시겠어?
그게 이제 왜 그러냐면
대표에서 할 수 있는 그 상대방의 진정성과
대표가 연락할 수 있는 인프라가 사실 직원이랑 다르잖아요.
그래서 대표가 직접 가서 계속 전화하고 얘기하는 모션만 보여줘도
조금...
근데 이거 다 끊는 아닙니다.
그냥 적...
그렇게 하는 게...
그래서 적었어요.
이제 심표위 소음을 생활하려고 그랬는데
박 팀장에게 넘겨볼까 좀 생각해 볼게요.
어때요?
저는 뭐...
아침에 아침 방송하고
저녁 방송하고
저녁 방송도 하고
그다음에 커머스도 하고
커머스도 하고
출장도 나가고
출장도 가야지.
그렇지.
그다음에 외부 촬영, 광부 촬영도 하고
해야지.
그렇지.
자네는 임원이잖아.
맞아요.
임원이니까 임원은 그...
임원은 진짜 열심히 해야 됩니다.
그렇죠.
임원은...
사실 임원은 사실 저희 회사를 본보기 삼아서 직원들이 따라 하잖아요.
그분이 잘못되면 진짜 회사가 무너질 수밖에 없다고 생각하거든요.
역시.
당연히 저는 당연히 열심히 하겠지만
임원이 저를 따라 하면 다 잘 되는 거잖아요.
그런데 임원이 진짜 좀 잘...
안 된다 하면 저는 빨리빨리 교체해줘야 된다고 생각합니다.
아아!
이번에 빨리 교체...
빨리빨리 교체...
야, 빨리빨리 교체가 왜 이렇게 길꽃이냐, 갑자기.
교체할 멤버가 없어요.
지금 덕아웃에 아무도 없어.
지금 우리는 투수가 한 명이에요.
전부 오탄이야.
어.
투수 타자 다 하고 있어, 지금.
덕아웃이 없어요, 지금.
자, 그래서 저희가 이제 오늘 또 아정당 대표님과 함께 이야기를 좀 나눴는데
마지막에 좀 어필을 하거나
회사에 대해서 마무리 주실 만한 어떤 이야기가 좋을까요?
사실 또 저희가 PPT를 안 보여드리고 가면...
좀 섭섭할 것 같아요.
아, 좋습니다.
보여주세요, 보여주세요.
좋아요, 좋아요.
휴대폰이 사는 방법이 두 가지가 있거든요.
온라인으로 사는 방법이 있고
오프라인으로 사는 방법이 있어요.
근데 이제 온라인은 번호 이동이 조금 더 많이 저렴하고
오프라인은 기기 변경이 많이 저렴해요.
그래서 두 가지 비교해서 사셔야 되는데
이제 저희가 그 저렴할 때 알림을 드려요.
그래서 이쪽에 알림을 받고...
가격이 저렴할 때가 있습니까?
네, 맞아요.
이 정책이 엄청 요동치고
많이 저희가 정책을 받을 때랑 적게 받을 때랑 한...
아, 4, 50만 원이요?
네, 맞습니다.
그러니까 그걸 폰 사실 이제 더 길게 쓰는 게 제일 이득이거든요.
그래서 폰 바꿔야 하는 시점이 급하지 않으신 분들은
이 카톡 친구 추가만 해두시고
그 알림 받고 사는 게 저렴하다라는 거 말씀드리려고 했고
저희가 이제 본사랑 다이렉트로 하고 있기 때문에
중간에 떼는 게 없습니다.
사실 휴대폰 진짜 까다롭게 되어 있거든요.
요금이나 조건이.
그래서 저희 야정당에 오시면 속을 일은 없다.
왜냐하면 이거 괜히 속였다가
기존 사업을 다 같이 무너뜨리고 싶지만
아정당이 가장 먼저 떠오르는 것을 바람으로 하고 있습니다.
열심히 하겠습니다.
네, 알겠습니다.
감사합니다.
오늘 저희 목요일에 늘 인사드리는
해피 떨세이.
아정당의 김민기 대표님과 함께
이렇게 이야기를 좀 나눠봤습니다.
지금 아정당이 만들어지는 과정들
그리고 이 기업에 대한 포인트들
또 여러 번 아낄 수 있는
또 알뜰하게 살 수 있는 그러한 것들을
아정당을 통해서 많이 활용해 주시면 어떨까 싶습니다.
오늘 해피 떨세이는 여전히
아정당의 아정당을 통해서
아정당을 통해서 많이 활용해 주시면 어떨까 싶습니다.
여기서 저희가 마치도록 하겠고요.
또 좋은 내용으로 여러분께 찾아뵙도록 하겠습니다.
감사합니다.
네, 감사합니다.
감사합니다. 고생하셨습니다.